[Music]
how does it make you feel tom when you
when you hear your name being mentioned
as the best ever
i i don't think i like it very much
truthfully i don't think that's
it's almost more uncomfortable for me
because i never see myself like that and
i you know i've always been underdog how
do you view yourself
because you remember before back in 2003
you told me while we're sitting down
having lunch i'm a six-round pick draft
choice
yeah that's your approach i still feel
that way i mean
i was a backup quarterback on an owen 8
freshman high school team
i didn't even play you know we didn't
win a game and i couldn't even get on
the field
you know i was a kind of a late bloomer
recruited to michigan late started as a
seventh quarterback
you know had to work really hard to even
play you know thought oh man i'll make
being pro football got drafted in the
sixth round
you know no one thought i'd make the
team so that drives you you know yeah it
still does i mean i think
now now it's like wait a minute now you
guys want me to stop playing
no this one this one i'm having fun you
know now is the time where i get to do
you know really enjoyed i always had a
lot of belief in myself and i always
tell a lot of young quarterbacks
you don't believe in yourself why do you
think those guys who are looking at you
are going to believe in you
you know when you step in that huddle
they better look at you and go man that
guy's ready to get the job done
because if they don't see that then
they're going to start questioning oh my
god i don't think that guy can get the
job done
so you got to believe in what you you
know who you are what you do what you
bring to the team
and then if you do that you know they're
going to feed off that as well
do you ever sit back and just really
appreciate
kind of what you've accomplished in your
life i mean do you ever sit back and
just say you know what
i did okay for myself i don't think no
i don't i don't unfortunately do you
take that as a weakness
being a weakness um i feel like i'm
still
you know if it's a marathon and there's
26 miles in the marathon i don't think
it mile
you know 21. what mile are you at right
now i think
21 21 22. you know i think if i'm
if i'm in mile 21 you're not going man
that was a great 21 miles i ran you know
you're still thinking like
i still got four or five miles to go and
i got to make those my best miles and if
i don't like i'm letting myself down why
shouldn't i've got
you know i know what to do i know my
players i know the offense you know i
feel good like why shouldn't these be
great games you know so i think it's
probably more frustrating i think
managing
frustration is probably harder for me
now than it was when i was younger
because when you're younger you may be
accepted at a lower standard
and as you get older you realize you've
seen the best
you know i played with hall of famers i
played against hall of famers
you know you you see the best and that's
what you aspire to be every day
so how do you deal with frustrations
when it's less than that you know when
you score
i said earlier this year we scored a few
games where we scored 38 points we
should have scored 50. i was frustrated
you know before we scored 13 points and
we won i was happy
because you guys would give up seven
points or no points
you know so i think that's a little bit
of a difference and i think just
managing my overall
you know positive outlook which i
i try to have but you know there's a lot
of daily frustrations
you talk about those frustrations have
you had to kind of adjust
your leadership style in order to relate
to this younger locker room in a younger
generation
you know i feel like i i feel like i do
that
naturally i feel like i have a great
camaraderie with the guys i play with
the guys i used to play with i still do
because i genuinely care about
the guys that i play with i mean i care
about the guys that i've played with
the guys in the locker room i'm trying
to help them you know reach their
potential in their career if i can help
them in any way
that's a great benefit to me i had you
to look up to i'd really look up to
i teddy to look up to i had drew bledsoe
to look up to
you know lawyer malloy all the great
players that i saw and i was lucky
to to play with those guys now they're
looking at me in the same way
so what can i do to help them you know
what advice can i give them how can i
sit down with them and
help them be a better player now the one
thing that i see
you don't you don't hesitate to yell and
scream i mean
whether you're yelling and screaming
kind of out in the wind
or whether yelling and screaming at one
of your guys i mean
do the young guys take to that yeah
absolutely i mean i think you by the way
you yelled a lot too
so this is i mean i think you're
that there's a purpose to that too you
know and it's a different time too tom
back when i was yelling at guys
we were older we had a lot of veteran
players yeah
and the young generations they're a lot
different now they're a little bit more
sensitive
i think yelling to yell isn't the point
i think it's yelling to create
urgency and to change states of mind is
what's important
you know they know me typically is very
poised someone that's very composed in
the meetings who's
you know wants to communicate you know
in a very mature way
you know in the in the locker room in
the meeting room
when i get on the field if i'm you know
communicating differently
you know i'm trying to say listen like
we're not getting it done like there's
we need more urgency we need more focus
more attention you know you got to play
harder we need more effort
you know and then hopefully you can just
that's part of being a leader on the
field is
you know getting everyone rise to the
occasion so i think i have both parts of
me you know and being able to
communicate to them in the locker rooms
different than on the field
but the stakes are different than the
locker room on the field you're not
but they trust you yeah they trust me
and they trust that you know i'm trying
to do it
in all of our best interests i'm not
trying to do it to to show them up or
anything so
i've never had a problem with that have
you seen that um
um nbc promo with michael jordan and he
talks about the greatest
of all time i did i was actually laying
there and i wasn't looking i was getting
treatment with alex and
i heard michael jordan's voice and
didn't know who i was literally and i
was looking up at the ceiling and i hear
this
commercial and it was just last sunday
night
and uh i'm like what's mj talking about
who's playing you know
it's lebron and who you know and then i
looked up and it's a football promo
so i got to ask you who's your guy mj or
lebron who you going with
and you better answer don't give me that
political i'm not i'm not answering that
question
how can you not answer the question
because i don't i don't even like that
question it's a hypothetical question
there's no
we want to hear what you have to say
about it it's michael jordan or it's
lebron james
i love them i love them both i love them
i'll tell you this i love them both
and you know what i think that's the
right answer because how could you
choose one
they're they're different they compete
differently are you saying a game on one
on one like
that's not fair all right ten seconds
left
you're down by one who you giving the
ball to
michael jordan or lebron because i know
if it's football who i'm giving it to
i'm giving it to
number 12. who are you giving it joe
montana was pretty
amazing at that too i'm giving it to you
hey you giving it to
i don't know i don't know
you're going to answer that question
i know